the team in Houston has already played
its first preseason game the Houston
Texans taking on the Carolina Panthers
this past Wednesday and we're pleased to
have here on the riches and she won
during its ninth year out of Southern
California Brian Cushing how are you
Brian I appreciate you having me you
very you bet so let's let's get started
right here what do you make of the
quarterback situation on your team Brian
you know we got we got three to three
guys competing for a job you know
obviously Tommy is a started right now
with the Shawn behind him two guys that
you know it's kind of it's not up in the
air right now but two guys that are just
you know really relaxed I've see Tom a
little bit more established and Shawn
come into the league this year has shown
you know flashes really some great
things and you know we've seen comfort
for three years going on four years now
so you know it's obviously gonna be
decision up to the coaches and
truthfully believe that the best man
will play but it's definitely a battle
now I know football is all about
controlling what you can control and you
can't control anything on that side of
the football so how has it been to watch
the revolving door at that position and
and I'm imagining you you'd like it to
stop and on one of them what what has it
been like for you in the defense Brian
it's just just trying to focus on
ourselves best spot so you know you said
it best you controlling what we can
control we understand that so we have a
job doing defensive side of the ball and
we just try to lead as best as possible
you know I've been here for nine years
I've seen an obviously great amount of
quarterbacks throughout the years but at
the same time just worrying about the
middle linebacker position getting the
call to the guys getting all the checks
around to everyone and just trying to
lead the guys as best as I possibly can
so then who is tom savage for those who
might not know the type of guy that he
is he's a good guy he's a good guys good
quarterback he's smart you know he's
been in coach O'Brien system now for
four years so he gets a really good
handle and grasp on everything you know
he makes him really good checks he's
made some really good throws in practice
he's going against pretty good defense
too so it's a good judge every day he of
talent and where he's at to go against
and how are so and then deshaun Watson
what has he been like in the first
couple weeks you've been exposed to him
right um
pretty much everything you expect them
better in Austin you know the guy is
just extremely talented person the
things that he does on a football field
kind of you know kind of awesome times
so you know obviously he's just got to
continue to grasp
a book understanding as best we possibly
can continue to grow and develop into a
quarterback and he'll do a great job so
would you when you're entering your
ninth season and you know how things can
go quickly in the NFL Brian would you
have a problem with a rookie starting
week one no you know in at the same time
you know like I said that is not up to
me but you know I played with rookie
quarterbacks before I played with guys
that just came off the street the
previous week so you know it's just kind
of a next man up attitude and whoever's
calling the shots and then and you know
throwing the ball on that side on that
side of the ball we're fine with you
know we understand that we just got to
play as best offensively as we possibly
can and lead them and you know like I
said it's just a big collective effort
Brian Cushing joining me here on the
Rich Eisen show after Houston's played
its first preseason game against the
Carolina Panthers and again Greg Olson
will be joining me here on the show
shortly before Emmitt Smith does how is
how how is your body
entering year nine Brian advisor good
another person was probably good
it's a I've been pleasantly surprised
with how I felt you know I've had some
injuries throughout my career that I've
really just gotten over you know I'm
just glad and very happy and blessed to
still be playing very fortunate so every
day every day I come out here I'm just
extremely happy to be playing football
still and honest and going here nine I
feel fresh I feel good you know I feel
experienced and you know I'm ready to
play for a good amount of time so do you
talk would what about you know
maintaining health it since he's had two
issues absolutely you know what you know
kind of deal he went through last year
just trying to you know keeping positive
and have him understand you know every
day that goes by is just one day close
to playing again you know that's what
kind of kept me going through those two
years it was my driving force so you
know anything I can help him out you
know it's something that's been there
and done that you know I'm definitely
there for him so what do you talk about
like give me some specifics about
keeping your head clear when you're
trying to get out like I talked about
you know just you know every single day
goes by it's close to playing football
game that's the biggest thing you're
going to have your good days you can
have your bad days that's just how rehab
goes in any substantial injury so it's
just never getting to down and
understanding you know you know good
chance your best days are still ahead of
you there's ton of football still
playing you're going to help this team
win obviously with kind of caliber and
talent that he has so he's definitely
help us big time so far who are we not
talking about on the Texans that
deserves that the pub Bryant who we not
don't know I don't know I think I kind
of - you use that right you yeah yeah
yes there's a bunch of good players if
we talked about the Shawn you know talk
about JJ I see DeAndre Lamar all those
guys so I mean Jonathan Joseph there's
there's a ton of good experienced
players there's a ton of good guys ton
of talent and the biggest thing is its
competitive team every day goes back and
forth offense defense and you know
that's a sign of good team but we got to
continue to work at it Super Bowl being
mentioned around they're talking right
now it obviously you talked about it and
where it comes up at the same time we
know we're far far away is away from it
so obviously that's all 32 teams and
goals and we understand that including
ours so you know we love to have that of
course any team would by the same time
we got to put a ton of work before we
can even really start to mention that
word your teammate David quest and Barry
played in his first game since being
diagnosed with cancer three years ago
what does his return meant to the team
it says it's an incredible story for an
awesome human being you know I mean you
know see what David went through three
years and kind of personality his and
obviously uh not country you know I
don't think I ever saw Dave not not a
smile during any of those days I saw
more have a positive outlook and we know
tell you know I'll be back I'll be back
and you know he obviously had his let
downs and then he was kind of his pull
along longer than he originally thought
but it kid never gave up and I mean you
want to talk about just an incredible
person incredible teammate just such an
unselfish you know team ain't player
everything he's just an awesome awesome
human be a couple more minutes with
Brian Cushing Texas linebacker here in
the Rich Eisen show where you holding
out hope that Vince Wilfork might give
it one more go you know there's a couple
helicopters landing out here in the
Greenbrier and I had a little hope that
he'd be on one's dinner but he probably
won't be able to be held up in a
helicopter so I knew it wasn't him okay
that's that's how you could tell that he
was at it he's definitely something
bigger than that agree well what'd you
learn from him what'd you pick up from
Vince bean I learned a lot you know I
learned a lot from Vince just a wise old
ballplayer who
I'm still moving I'm strong as an ox but
no just one of those guys that was an
awesome teammate just a ton of
leadership a ton of experience
definitely he kind of handed out to all
of us and then I just had the pleasure
of playing behind them for two years was
was incredible you know obviously every
single play demands a double team with a
guy of that size and that athletic
ability and you know there's a really
cool experience playing with him you
know both on and off the field and do
you think you could pull off the
dungaree overall look quite like Vince
Ryan it would uh it looked a little
different I definitely need a smaller
size you think so yeah so probably
hopefully somebody has them enshrined
somewhere I'd love I love shooting
bronzed they're around their self around
here somewhere yeah and what do you
think of your Trojans this year
preseason number four yeah what do you
think Brian I'm excited I'm excited
every year for them I mean not if you
know it's been a while since it kind of
you know returned back to that caliber
play it had gone through some things but
I mean this is extremely talented team
in that quarterback is as good as as
anyone out there in college football so
excited for that I'm excited every year
but this year's got a little bit their
guilt yeah I mean a lot of folks think
Sam Donald's going to be number one
overall do you see an NFL quarterback
when you you watch him play uh yeah I
think so I think so for sure you believe
we finally lost Brian that was going in
and out right there now when you drop a
call like that yes do you call back
right away
or do you expect the person who called
to call back it's nice to say goodbye
kind of formally end the conversation I
need closure right exact lozer guy he's
calling back in is that him right there
Ron you there yeah yeah yeah I'm that we
can hear you and we were just talking
around I know the policy and everything
I'm a big I'll call you back every
timers don't worry about it is that what
it is that is your policy on that
seriously I'm you know I don't know it's
just one of those things where I feel I
got a call back obviously you guys are
still talking and I was lost so I'll
find my way back there yeah I appreciate
that I'm a closure guy too Brian
you know I don't know you close for a
living yes you know so I just like
closure I felt
we were wrapping up you know now I'm
back go back okay so you were saying you
saw you see an NFL quarterback at Sam
Donald yeah I think so I think the
defense potential the mental is all
there and uh you know I've seen he's got
a little bit of football still playing
and a lot to learn but his age where
he's at
you know he's uh he's advanced for sure
or in that dropped moment you were
talking crap about Belichick and how
you're gonna kick the Patriots ass right
Brian
is that a hostile thomassie I'm still
talking I oh okay okay yeah yeah I tried
you see how I tried right there that's
called phishing good alright Brian you
take care thanks for calling back like I
should I mean I appreciate it guys
Broncos
so Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on radio stations across the
country and audience if you like that
downloading around please just if it's a
memory thing just delete other apps you
don't need those apps this app the Rich
Eisen show app you need that